عندما يتعلق الأمر بالحرب لأننا تحدثنا
عن حقيقة أنه يمكن استخدامها في
الحرب ،
فهل هي أخطر من الحرب على سبيل المثال
أو الحرب النووية بالطريقة التي نفكر بها في
الحرب التقليدية ، فإن أسوأ سيناريو
هو أن الحرب النووية مروعة وأي
نوع من  قد يؤدي اندلاع حريق نووي كبير إلى
تدمير العالم كما نعرفه ،
يمكنك تخيل هذه التكنولوجيا ، على
سبيل المثال ، الهجمات الإلكترونية النشطة على
دولة بأكملها تفعل ذلك حتى
يموت الجميع ويمكنك أن تتخيل هذا السيناريو ،
يمكنك أيضًا تخيل السيناريو الذي
تقول فيه أنني أريد قتل
يظهر لي مليون شخص مسارًا بيولوجيًا للقيام بذلك ، هذه
هي المخاطر التي يتعين علينا
التأكد من عدم حدوثها ، نحتاج إلى وضع
قضبان حراسة وحدود الأشخاص الذين
يعملون على حل هذه المشكلات ، فنحن لا
نفهم الحلول تمامًا ، لكن إريك
شميدت أنت فقط  أرعبني